meantime welcome in here at 11 o'clock
helping you navigate housing issues amid
the cobit 19
pandemic that was the goal of an online
event tonight which was hosted by clark
county officials
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftness topics touched on
tonight include
tenants rights how to get rental
assistance and how to respond to an
eviction notice
orco mana joining us now with what help
is out there for folks
who are struggling orco
well brian and denise thousands of
nevada families are worried about having
a place to stay
because of the eviction moratorium being
lifted but clark county officials
held a virtual town hall tonight saying
there is help available
but tenants just need to take action now
i'm homeless so i have to find somewhere
to stay
the effect of evictions already hitting
nevada family's heart the statewide
eviction moratorium expired on october
15
but there are other ways to get help i
want to give you some information clark
county leaders along with housing and
legal experts held a town hall monday
night they're reminding tenants of their
rights including making sure they file
an affidavit within one week of getting
an eviction notice
during that seven days the landlord may
not proceed
with the eviction once you file that
tenant's affidavit
it basically preserves your right to a
hearing in terms of getting financial
help right now
county recently launched a new website
for the carous housing assistance
program or chap people who have suffered
financial hardship due to covet 19 can
apply but they must show documented
proof of that hardship and must meet
other criteria
payments will be made directly to the
landlord the county says the most
important thing to do right now is go to
chap.clarkcounty.gov and put your name
in the system
even if you have incomplete information
get in the portal
okay so we can do our work and we'll
help you with your landlord
also available is the cdc moratorium
which can stop
evictions through december 31st tenants
who meet these criteria including
showing that you've used your best
efforts to get help must fill out and
sign a declaration form and give it to
their landlord preferably by certified
mail keep a copy for yourself and
there's also a new safeguard
after you sign and send your cdc tenant
declaration
you can file a cdc proof of service with
the court
to go on a record that you have
submitted this to your landlord
while the protection lasts through the
end of the year many are worried about
what happens
afterward the county says they're
planning for next steps
we are right now working on budgets to
support deposits and rental assistance
programming post
december 31st
again the carrots housing assistance
program and the cdc declaration form
are available but tenants need to act
now and you need to take the initiative
to do that
and clark county officials are urging
you to do so as soon as possible
reporting live tonight orcomanna 8 news
now